ohana means family
family means no one's left behind
or forgotten
so much for that apparently
[Music]
hello there folks so we have to deal
with
topical stuff again
and
hopefully fingers crossed no major
developments happen between when i
record this and when
um it actually is scheduled to go up let
me just go ahead and stop you right
there past me that proved to be a sadly
optimistic hope this thing has continued
to evolve and at a much faster pace than
i expected i am actually recording this
bit the morning that the video goes up
because stuff won't stop happening so
here's what i'm going to ask you to keep
in mind i am going to be talking quite a
bit in this video about how disney has
not issued any kind of specific apology
nor has its ceo properly addressed what
has gone on now as of the day before
this video goes up there's been
reporting around some specifics that if
you're already aware of might make you
go wait isn't some of the stuff that
they're saying hasn't happened actually
happened and yes but i'm not going to
redo this entire video for two reasons
one i have spent way too much time on
this already and two i actually think
there is value in preserving in a way
the timeline of what has gone on so that
you understand the process by which we
got to where we are and what a roller
coaster this entire thing has been and i
do feel that leaving in things as i
originally intended with addendums as we
go we'll preserve that much better than
trying to start all over don't worry at
the end i will come back to the latest
stuff that's gone on okay let's go we
are going to be talking about
what is colloquially known as the don't
say gay bill which has passed the state
house in florida and the governor ron
desantis has indicated he is likely to
sign into law and how would the moving
forward of that bill has come to affect
the disney company
now
there's actually a lot uh to go over
because
the whole situation is a lot more
complicated
than a lot of the discourse i've seen a
lot of the discourse has been dealing
with the very stripped-down summary of
what's been going on and while i'm not
going to say a lot of it's inaccurate it
is incomplete and what i wanted to do
here was do as complete a look at what
is going on as possible
i'm breaking this into three major parts
one discussing the law itself which is
probably going to be the driest portion
of this because i am going to be reading
some of the
exact wording of the bill yeah i did
read it it wasn't the hardest thing in
the world it's only seven pages it's not
the densest legalese in the world but
i'm going to discuss the bill itself
what's actually in it and the
implications of it and what is liable to
happen as a result of it
second part will be discussing how it
has been linked to disney
and then a third part discussing how
disney has been dealing with
these connections and my thoughts
on
how they have been doing that so
my own opinions should not be difficult
for anyone to parse just to look at me
but i will be giving them throughout but
the final section is going to focus on
my thoughts in regards to disney
in
specific i'll give you the quick
overview the law is terrible
the fact that disney is linked to the
support of it is not inaccurate but is a
little bit more nuanced and complicated
than people are saying and disney has
not been doing a great job at responding
to those connections that's the short
version but we've got
a lot to go through starting with the
law itself the law that we are talking
about is house bill 1557
officially called parental rights in
education
so the don't say gay is the term being
used by mainly opponents of it because
they're basically talking about the
practical outcome
of this law as opposed to the wording
that the law itself is
aiming for now this bill was sponsored
by state senator dennis baxley and state
representative joe harding those two
names are going to come up again but i
don't want to let anybody off the hook
here so in addition to that
it was also co-sponsored by state
representatives barrero fernandez
barquin fine lotvala maggard roach and
snyder these are the people who have
brought the bill forward now that's not
a full list of everyone who voted in
favor of it
but that those are the main sponsors and
the co-sponsors now the version of the
bill that i went over is dated from the
22nd of february now
there have been attempts to add more
amendments since then they haven't
passed so this version is the one that
is being presented to the governor to
sign off on so this is the version that
will be going into effect now i'm not
going to read the entire thing front to
back because that's more dry than i'm
prepared to get i am going to focus on
the specific sections that really
directly impact
the practical outcomes and it's why
people are calling it the don't say gay
bill
so this is all about
parents
students
and school districts
so with that in mind let's start
with section one the procedures must
reinforce the fundamental right of
parents to make decisions regarding the
upbringing and control of their children
by requiring school district personnel
to encourage a student to discuss issues
relating to his or her well-being with
her his or her parent or to facilitate
discussion of the issue with the parent
now right off the bat we're already
getting into one of the big quagmires of
this which is this is codifying into law
a requirement
of teachers and school districts to
bring things to the attention of parents
now before you say well why wouldn't
they bring things to the attention of
parents let me jump in with a little bit
more personal information from me
i have in the course of my life been
very close to a number of educators who
have given me stories not specifically
related to this but like i've just heard
over time of students who were some form
of lgbtqia plus be it gay be it bisexual
be it trans be it non-binary who came
from homes where that was not supported
and those teachers did their best to
support those students at the school
knowing that there was no support for
them at home now while as worded it does
not specifically say
that teachers have to inform parents
that their kid is trans or requesting
different pronouns or whatever it does
say anything related to their mental
well-being and it is very easy to make
the argument because it's true that a
disconnect between how someone is able
to present themselves at school and how
they feel it is safe for them to present
at home is not good for their mental
well-being and so now any teacher
noting that has a requirement to notify
the parents
that's regardless of whether or not they
believe that will be harmful to the
student and if you think i'm overreading
that
stick with me i will back up what i just
said
section two a school district may not
adopt procedures or student support
forms that prohibit school district
personnel from notifying a parent about
his or her student's mental emotional or
physical health or well-being or a
change in related services or monitoring
or that encourager have the effect of
encouraging a student to withhold from a
parent such information so this is now
also tying the school's hand saying you
can't put your own rules in place to
carve out exceptions for the first part
that we said and again the specific
phrase of
a change in related services or
monitoring is pretty directly without
saying flat out talking about the way a
student wishes to present this is kind
of the official terminology for a
student wishing to be referred to by a
different name or different pronouns
than what might be on their legal
documentation that is a change in
monitoring that is a change in how the
teachers being requested to interact
with the students that is now required
to be reported to parents regardless of
how the parents feel about transition or
lgbtqia plus people and i'll inject
another personal thing here i understand
some folks really don't get why
informing the parents is going to be a
problem
i'm going to let you know something here
years ago i used to have a series on the
vera wild channel called deer vera where
i would answer questions that i received
through email now
a frighteningly common thing that i
found myself having to do and it broke
my heart every time i had to do it was
there were more than a few times
where i
felt it necessary to advise
young trans people who were still living
at home and still under the care and
control of their parents who knew to a
near certainty that their parents would
not support them and would likely eject
them from the home i had to advise those
people you probably shouldn't come out
to your parents because so many of them
came to me asking what can i say to make
them understand hoping that i could give
them some kind of secret magical phrase
that would make them supportive but it
doesn't exist
and i'm not even an educator
but i have had to repeatedly
because i thought it was the best out of
a lot of bad options advise young trans
people
you probably shouldn't tell your family
until you know for certain you have some
place to go if your home becomes no
longer safe
whether it be with friends with a
supportive relative if you have the
ability now to support yourself and be
outside the home
then
that is the time to possibly try this if
you do it too soon it is
well it's the reason why lgbtqia plus
individuals make up a disproportionate
percentage of homeless youth because
they are rejected from homes and again
this law is requiring
the reporting back
of these sorts of things to parents
and those parents may
not be supportive at all
now the final sentence in section two is
where a whole lot of people are going to
say oh well clearly you're wrong because
of this sentence i'm going to read you
the sentence and in a little bit we'll
explain why
this actually doesn't make a difference
this subparagraph does not prohibit a
school district from adopting procedures
that permit school personnel to withhold
such information from from a parent if a
reasonably prudent person would believe
that disclosure would result in abuse
abandonment or neglect as those terms
are defined in statute 39.01
now you would be forgiven for hearing
that and thinking that well i clearly
just blew out of proportion all the
things that came before because here's
the section that says if they think the
parents will be negligent abandoning or
or otherwise will
be harmful and abusive to the child they
don't have to report that
well
two things the first is i did actually
take a look at that statute for the
definition of abuse as defined under
florida statute 39.01
and
i was originally planning to go over
that statute and how it's pretty vague
in a lot of areas and the only place
where it does get specific is in aspects
of physical abuse it makes references to
emotional abuse and mental abuse but
gives no specific citations of what sort
of things to look out for and even its
laying out of what physical abuse is is
more about saying anything that is short
of this we do not count as physical
abuse but i'm not going to go any more
detailed than that broad overview i just
gave you because something we're going
to cover in a little bit means that it
doesn't matter anyways
getting back to hb1557
section 3. classroom instruction by
school personnel or third parties on
sexual orientation or gender identity
may not occur in kindergarten through
grade three
or in a manner that is not
age-appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students in accordance
with state standards now i was not able
to find those specific state standards
that it is referencing because it didn't
give me a specific statute to refer to
so i couldn't find out more detail on
that here's what i can say about this
whole section though it eliminates even
bringing up the topics of identity or
sexual orientation for kindergarten
through third grade now again there may
be people out there going why would you
be talking to kids that young about that
anyway here's the thing what you're
probably imagining in your head is some
sort of sit down talk like a sex ed
conversation with these kids that
generally is not what actually happens
again
i while i may not live in florida i have
i am and have been friends with many
educators at many grade levels including
as young as kindergarten the way in
which the ideas of gender identity or
sexual orientation are brought up to
kids that young is as innocuous as
reading a picture book where a character
has two parents of the same gender
that's the kind of degree to which it
gets brought up in those classes or
maybe there is a student in the class
who has family members who are same-sex
couples or who
who maybe they themselves or someone
else in their family has a gender
identity that is not what they were
assigned at birth and it allows for that
conversation to be had that child to
talk about it
for other students to talk about it to
put it into context of the greater world
this law would prohibit
any of that even if it has direct
applicability to the students in the
classroom the law seems to be built
around the idea that children have no
encountering of any of this stuff from
kindergarten through third grade and
certainly not before but the fact is
that's simply not true not because
they're being taught about it in any
formal event but just because that's a
part of a lot of their lives but now
suddenly it's a part of their lives that
is not allowed to be discussed or
brought up at all
and because i could not find those state
standards for the grades over third
grade i do not know how restrictive
those actually are
but a bit like the thing about concerns
of parental abuse as a result it
actually doesn't matter how restrictive
the things are because of again
something we're going to get to in a
little bit now we get to jump ahead to
section 6. before administering a
student well-being questionnaire or
health screening form to a student
kindergarten through grade 3 the school
district must provide the questionnaire
or health screening form to the parent
and obtain permission of the parent now
i did look into what a well-being
questionnaire consists of generally
speaking obviously they kind of vary
depending on where you are and who's
written the thing but broadly speaking
it is what it sounds like it is a
questionnaire to determine the general
well-being both positive and negative of
the individual that is being asked these
questions
the idea that
even concerned teachers administrators
nurses anybody involved in the school
cannot administer a questionnaire to try
and just get a better sense of is a kid
actually okay without first
not only alerting the parents but
seeking their permission meaning the
reason why these kids might not be okay
has to sign off on them being asked
whether or not they're okay
do we not see how fundamentally messed
up that is
and i'm not trying to over inflate the
notion of parental abuse but the simple
fact is kids at that age
if somebody is causing them distress and
harming their well-being statistically
it is most likely their parents or
another family member next up section
seven each school district shall adopt
procedures for a parent to notify the
principal or his or her designee
regarding concerns under this paragraph
at his or her student school and the
process of resolving those concerns
within seven calendar days of
notification by the parent now this in
and of itself isn't awful although the
seven calendar days really did make me
raise an eyebrow seven calendar days not
seven business days not seven working
days not seven school days seven
calendar days so my kids winter break
started on the 22nd of december in this
most recent year it did not end until
the third of january so in theory if
this law were an application where i
lived back at that time
a parent could have notified their
concerns to a school on the 21st and
then because it's seven calendar days
the school everyone who is be wrapped up
in this administrative specific teacher
etc would have to be working over the
course of a vacation to have it done
within seven days making seven calendar
days is really weird and makes it rife
for abuse by people who wish to cause
the most inconvenience and trouble
possible so now we get to the section
why i said various other things didn't
matter like what the actual state
guidelines for talking about gender or
sexual identities or orientations are
doesn't matter why the fact that there
is a written carve out so that teachers
or school administrators don't have to
tell parents if they think it will
result in abuse don't matter those
exceptions do not matter because of this
section
section 7b a parent may request the
commission of education to appoint a
special magistrate who is a member of
the florida bar in good standing and has
at least five years experience in
administrative law so i'm not going to
read everything in between that and the
next section i'm going to go over but it
then lays out primarily a time table
through which the magistrate will
conduct its investigation gather the
facts make a recommendation to the board
of education of florida who will then
either accept or reject that
recommendation but the thing we really
gotta deal with is the last sentence
the cost of the special magistrate shall
be borne by the school district
hold that in your head we're not quite
done yet a court may award damages and
shall award reasonable attorney fees and
court costs to a parent who receives
declaratory or injunctive relief first
of all
while it does lay out an ability for
parents to sue and receive relief
through the courts and in addition makes
it so they can recoup their legal costs
there is no
written language
giving the school district a means to
recoup any incurred legal cost and that
first bit the special magistrate will be
paid for by the school district that
is in all
cases no matter what happens the instant
a special magistrate is appointed and
needs to start being paid for their time
the school district is the one who has
to pay it regardless of whether the
school district ends up being victorious
and proven right in their assertions of
how they went about things regardless of
whether the parent changes their mind
and withdraws their protest the school
will still have to bear that cost and
this is why i said the other stuff
doesn't
matter hey there folks it's vera
speaking from the editing phase of this
so i feel like i need to add one quick
note before i get any further into the
video i realized while editing that it
seems like i'm implying that it should
fall to the parents to pay for the
special magistrate that was not my
intention my point was more that there
is zero mechanism by which the school
can be financially exonerated for the
burden it takes on there is no funding
set aside there is no sort of way for
them to recoup from the state from
anywhere i'm not saying that that burden
should automatically fall onto the
parents or that it should be retaliatory
paid for by the parents if the parents
lose but i'm saying the fact that the
school has zero means of recouping that
cost by any mechanism whatsoever is a
problem i don't have a suggestion for
what the best mechanism would be i'm not
a legislator i'm pointing out the
problems with the fact that there is
none okay back to it
because the simple fact is
that anybody
has the ability at effectively zero cost
to themselves
even if they don't take the step of
actually suing them in court they have
the ability to rack up costs for the
school district by protesting something
that occurred whether it be something
that was brought up something that was
taught or the fact that something was
withheld from them even if it was a case
where the teacher or school or whoever
thoroughly believed and maybe even
rightfully believed that informing the
the parent would result in abuse or
neglect
that parent can still request the
magistrate and the school has to pay for
it no
matter
what
what this means from a strictly
financially incentivized position is the
best thing for schools to do
is to never
ever find themselves in a position where
they have to pay for a magistrate
which means that that wiggle room that
was in the earlier language about well
there's an exception if they think it's
going to be um if it's going to result
in abuse but
the supposed abuser
can still cause them to rack up costs
and no matter how strongly the school
may feel about any given individual
instance
these things can be brought against them
completely without merit the magistrate
would actually have the job of finding
out whether there's any merit to this in
the first place and even if there's zero
merit the school
pays the cost so the only way for the
school not to lose
massive amounts of their funding is to
simply never
ever broach the subject or rock the boat
regardless of what they think is
actually best for the students on an
individual or a group basis
all the power has been handed to people
who don't like
any kind of information being provided
to their kids about the mere existence
of alternate sexualities to heterosexual
and alternate gender identities to
cisgender and they do not need to prove
a basis of complaint in order to rack up
costs for the school costs that a school
will probably not be able to bear
multiple times across a year from
multiple parents
this
is where the real damage happens because
regardless of the wording of anything
else schools can't afford they can't
afford it they cannot afford to advocate
for their own students in the face of
something like this
and this is why it's called the don't
say gay bill
because the instant you approach the
topic at all you have opened yourself up
to possibly full legal liability of
being sued and again even if you win
that you don't get your court costs back
if you're the school the parents might
if they win but even if the school wins
there's no carve out to say that they
can get their court costs back but even
if you're not brought to court you got
to pay for the special magistrate who is
a lawyer who is going to bill hourly and
you have to do that every time there is
a complaint
no school can afford that this law for
the record if signed by the governor
will go into effect on july 1st
and again
strictly speaking by the wording of the
law in theory
parents of kids could also complain
that the school is pushing heterosexual
as a as an identity in the same way that
parents could object to
the idea of it
pushing homosexuality simply by bringing
up same-sex parents the thing is
that doesn't actually swing both ways
because
parents of
kids who want them to have a more
complete education don't actually want
to remove the discussion of
heterosexuality and for them to do so
would only hurt the school anyway
so
again on paper
there are the exceptions that are
necessary and theoretically
the same complaints could be made about
pushing heterosexuality and cis
normativity but in practical terms
neither of those things will ever happen
and the complaints being made are only
ever gonna come about
from people who object
to anything that isn't cisgender and
anything that isn't heterosexual
and there's one last interesting thing
that i found out about this bill that i
want to add in here i looked at some of
the amendments that were brought up and
either were or weren't added and there
was one that really stood out to me this
was one of the last ones uh proposed and
it was not adopted and this appeared to
be somebody's attempt to try and
mitigate the damage this bill is going
to do there was a proposal for an
amendment which would have required the
schools to
make available a pamphlet to students
and teachers and that pamphlet would
have been created in conjunction with at
least two lgbtqia groups in this
particular case pflag and glsen this
appeared to be an attempt to basically
say okay look we grant that the parents
have control over whether or not
students are made aware of this but we
want to be sure that the parents have
access to good information at the very
least we can't force them to pass these
on to their kids we can't force them to
agree with them but we can make it a
requirement that these are available so
that we know parents have access to the
information that well was not added it
would have been a band-aid if it had
been but somebody tried so that's the
law
now we need to get into how disney is
tied to this now the way i've seen it
reported in a lot of places is that
disney backed the bill
or that disney backed every single
person who sponsored the bill now
neither of those are completely accurate
i want to say they're lies but they are
a little bit misunderstandings disney
has not directly backed the bill
financially they can't corporations
don't financially back direct
legislation they can voice their
approval or disapproval of a law
certainly and some companies do that
disney itself has done that in other
cases some of which i'll bring up but
they have actually said nothing flat out
about the law itself positive or
negative now as for the idea that they
have funded everyone who has sponsored
the bill there's one of two things going
on there uh the first is
that might be referring to just dennis
baxley and joe harding because
certain parts of the disney company have
financially backed the re-election
campaigns of both of those i'll get into
specifics on that in a little bit but i
couldn't find confirmation of any of the
co-sponsors of the bill who i named
earlier now the source for saying that
disney backed all of them that seems to
have its origins in a piece written in
the orlando sentinel which unfortunately
i was not able to read myself because
it's behind a paywall and i wasn't going
to pay to read it i did note however
that it was in the opinion section and
that makes me a little bit dubious i'm
not going to definitively say that
disney has not done financial backing
for any of the numerous co-sponsors i
will say i could not independently
verify that i could get verification of
baxley and harding i tried to go deeper
into this to check on the others i even
went to florida's campaign finance
database but the thing is labyrinthine
and really badly designed and i am not
good enough at that kind of research to
try and parse that thing so i let it go
so from here on out we are going to be
focusing on how disney has financed joe
harding and dennis baxley now the first
thing to point out is that the disney
company the parent company has made no
financial donations to either of these
people however various elements and
smaller companies within it have and i
was able to find details on this in a
number of places such as the independent
and according to what i could find
baxley's 2022 reelection campaign
received a thousand dollars from disney
photo imaging meanwhile harding's 2022
re-election campaign received a thousand
dollar donations from disney
destinations llc disney gift card
service incorporated and disney photo
imaging inc so for the upcoming 2022
re-election for both of these candidates
it has been a total of four thousand
dollars donated to their campaigns from
various entities within disney probably
also worth bringing up is that in 2018
baxley also received a thousand dollar
donations from disney vacation
developments inc and disney destinations
llc
so
that's where the financing of the
sponsor of this bill come in now again
as i said the first thing to keep in
mind is the
big
disney capital d big disney
did not directly contribute to these
smaller entities within it did now does
that absolve them of any responsibility
no but i do want to create an
understanding where exactly at what
level this happened because with an
entity as large as disney is it is
honestly not reasonable for everybody
within the corporate structure or even
the people at the top to be aware
especially in advance of any specific
donations being made by a smaller entity
that has its own uh corporate structure
and its own heads
the people at the top or the people in
other parts of the company are not going
to be keeping tabs on what everybody
else is doing they're just they're not
now while i could not find specific
dates on these donations it is
incredibly unlikely that they were made
after the bill was proposed and was
being moved forward more likely they
would have been made at the time that
the campaign for re-elections were first
established for these candidates so
there is at least on paper the
possibility that the specific branches
of disney that were contributing to them
did not did not know that this was
something that was going to be moving
forward and it is possible or at least
arguable that had they known they would
not have made those donations
we don't know either way i'm just
allowing for the possibility hey folks
it's me again quick little note for
something that i have come to realize
since shooting this while in the case of
joe harding he is coming up his first
term in the florida legislature and had
no voting record prior to this current
term for anyone to know exactly what he
was going to do dennis baxley has been
pushing
anti-lgbtqia plus legislation since
2013. so i don't think anybody has an
excuse for not realizing he was going to
continue to do that it's a little bit of
plausible deniability with harding it
really is not with baxley okay back to
the other me but now that we know how
this ties into disney now we need to
talk about how disney big capital d
disney the disney company has been
responding to this and in particular we
need to bring up the current ceo bob
chappic because there's been a lot of
call for the company as a whole and for
him in particular to respond to this and
they have done so minimally and in
chappic's case not at all hey folks so
this will be the first of a couple
additional notes in this section because
this has been the most ongoing and
evolving portion of this entire thing so
chappic has sort of made some statements
or rather he's been attached to some
memos that have gone around internally
at disney i will address those as they
become relevant to the topic but before
anyone jumps down to the comments to say
oh he has said some stuff yeah kinda
sorta a little i'll deal with it when
it's relevant okay okay here we go now a
little bit about chappic in particular
he took over from bob iger in 2020 and
he is a much more low-key stays behind
the curtain sort of ceo than iger was
igor was not the most outspoken ceo in
the world but he was certainly more so
than chappic and unfortunately the
comparison is apt because eiger in
addition to abigail disney who is the
daughter of roy disney and the great
niece of walt disney have both come
forward saying how awful this law is in
various ways so
there are already people associated with
the disney brand though not directly
linked to it in any legal sense who are
saying this is terrible but the actual
company and the head of the company are
being pretty silent for the most part
now a little bit about chappic he is
currently registered as an independent
as of 2016 prior to that he had been
registered as a democrat now i don't
want to parse too much about the man's
personal politics because honestly he's
pretty quiet and private about them as
is his right however i don't think it is
a massive leap for people to assume that
he decided to become independent as
opposed to democrat to at the very least
free himself up in a political
philosophical sense to go in a more
conservative direction on specific
issues should he feel it to be necessary
that may not be the case but i don't
think that's going to be an uncommon
read on that simple fact now the
hollywood reporter did speak to an
unnamed individual who is a source close
to chapec who had a couple of specific
things to say they said that chapping is
staunchly opposed to bringing disney
into issues he deems irrelevant to the
company and its business
which
on the surface
fair enough except that disney is such a
massive company and its roots in florida
especially run so deep that to claim
that this is not impacting his business
especially a business that has in the
last few years been
heavily
marketing itself and pushing the idea of
it being lgbtqia inclusive and for the
record has been praised for its actual
workplace environment that working for
disney as an lgbtqia plus person is one
of the better companies to work for but
their reach goes far far beyond that i
mean they are a cultural monolith so to
it to
sort of sit back and say nothing on the
implication that this doesn't impact us
well no it does and you impact it
because companies that are part of you
helped make this happen
in an indirect way admittedly but they
did and while i do not feel that bob
chappeck or the disney company are
responsible for those initial donations
being made they do kind of have a
responsibility to reply and respond to
them in a meaningful sense especially if
they are going to continue to push and
merchandise to lgbtqia plus people and
their allies okay so this is the big
thing that's happened since i originally
shot this a memo from bob chappic about
everything going on has been released to
the press not officially which means
that neither disney itself has a company
nor chappic as an individual has
actually made a formal statement about
any of this and in fact part of the memo
talks about the fact that they have it
and gives reasonings why i am going to
be referring to this memo a few more
times across the remainder of this video
because frankly it's too much to go over
all of it in one chunk right here this
is me just giving me the heads up that
pretty much every time i jump in from
here until the end of the video is going
to be in reference to parts of this memo
and how it shifts or makes clearer any
of the points that i bring up later now
to come back to bob iger real quick i
think a good comparison here is when bob
iger spoke out against the georgia
heartbeat bill that passed there and has
been tied up in the courts ever since it
passed now when that initially passed he
felt that he had to speak about that
because parts of disney specifically
marvel are very entrenched in georgia a
lot of the shooting is done in atlanta
if you stay through the credits to catch
any post-credit scenes you've probably
seen a special thing about georgia with
the georgia peach towards the end of the
credits of pretty much every marvel
movie since disney has acquired them so
he recognized that it was necessary to
address the fact that disney was going
to continue to conduct his business
there because
realistically they had set up such an
apparatus there that trying to relocate
it was probably not economically viable
but he understood that he had to say
this is something we are not okay with
and anyone who works for us who feels
they cannot work in georgia we will
support and attempt to help and relocate
them and put them in a situation where
they are comfortable he had to say that
because he understood that to say
nothing was to tacitly endorse it simply
by virtue of how much money was being
pumped into the georgia economy by the
presence of marvel quick note on this i
feel like i come across as over praising
bob iger just a little bit while i do
think it was helpful and necessary that
he say the things that he said it's not
unfair if anyone wants to look back at
that now and feel that it's pretty
hollow he actually even implied that
disney might stop working within georgia
he implied that way back in 2019 that
never actually happened and with him no
longer in charge of disney it is now
even less likely to happen so it is
distinctly possible that all of this was
fairly empty but it did still mean that
they made
some point to say something which is
more than is being done now
so
whether you feel that is a largely empty
gesture or not from a strictly corporate
pr sense it was a very necessary one for
him to do and it's one that bob chappeck
seems unwilling to do in this similar
situation in a state where disney
arguably has even deeper roots than it
did in georgia now again to be clear
eiger didn't speak up all that much or
all that often considering how long he
was the ceo but he did on matters that
he felt strongly about or he felt that
it was important for the company to take
a stand about so i mentioned the georgia
heartbeat bill he had similarly strong
wording when trump implemented his
travel ban which prevented travel from
muslim majority countries into the
united states and he also left a
presidential advisory board in the wake
of trump pulling out of the paris
climate accords now while these are
statements they are not numerous he
wasn't constantly doing this this was
over the course of all his time as ceo
these were the most prominent examples
that i could find but he did make
certain statements that were leaning
into the image that disney has been
building bob chapping seems to want to
court a much more neutral image than
eiger seemed to be wanting it probably
doesn't help in this particular
circumstance that some of the people
chappick has appointed as his immediate
people that he works with such as his
chief of staff and his chief corporate
affairs officer both previously worked
in the george w bush administration
which again is not an exact
determination of what they do or don't
want to support but it does paint a
generalized picture which right now is
not helped by his silence now this isn't
to say that chapek is doing literally
nothing there does appear to be some
stuff in the works but it's all internal
at disney there are multiple planned
summits and meetings and conversations
and large-scale talks going on within
the disney company specifically to
address the concerns of lgbtqia plus
members of the staff and the employees
which
himself is scheduled to appear and talk
and be talked to i'll refer again to the
memo here because in it chappic does
bring up the upcoming reimagined
tomorrow summit being held for employees
of the company in april and he says that
there will be conversations had there it
means if there is any change in
direction in the company actually making
an official statement prior to that it
means that pressure has been so harsh
that they didn't even wait for the
summit to happen and if anything change
is coming out of it then it means that
employees were actually able to sway him
and if nothing changes coming out of
that it means that they were not able to
dissuade him from this current path of
saying nothing so some of you may be
wondering why does it matter why is it
necessary that he say something or that
disney make a statement
well first of all they did make a
statement i'll be dissecting that in a
minute but part of the reason is that
their silence is being taken overtly by
the people backing this bill as support
on the 4th of march dennis baxley said
and i quote disney has donated to my
campaign and many others they have a
world of interest on a variety of topics
that we address in the florida
legislature now strictly taken as a
comment in a vacuum
that's simply a statement of fact that
is factually true however it needs to be
remembered that that statement was made
in the context of baxley being asked
about hb1557
so when asked about that bill and about
disney in any way being linked to that
bill he said
they support all kinds of people who do
things that they feel is necessary
the
heavy
heavy implication that he is drawing is
that disney wants what he's doing
because if disney does not say anything
does not either specify
we
do not wish to support them any longer
which they have not said which has
resulted in some headlines being they
will continue to fund these people we
actually don't know if that's true they
may not but they haven't said that they
won't which leaves open the possibility
that they may continue to fund these
individuals okay memo time again nothing
in the memo contradicts what i just said
they still have not definitively said
that they will not fund these kinds of
politicians anymore however it was
addressed somewhat here's what is said
in the memo while we have not given
money to any politician based on this
issue we have contributed to both
republican and democrat legislators who
have subsequently taken position on both
sides of the legislation now this one is
a really weird and infuriating sentiment
basically saying look we're not
financing anybody because of their
stances on lgbtqia plus rights and the
people we finance have been on both
sides of that issue first of all i don't
know why he thinks invoking anything
even close to both sides arguments is in
any way a good idea for him right now
but beyond that this is basically him
admitting
we have absolutely no interest in what
the effects of the people we
give our money to have on the lgbtqia
plus community you're emitting flat out
we give them money because of other
things and then it impacts this other
thing that people are now upset about
sometimes positive sometimes negatively
we don't take that into account that's
again not the helpful admission you seem
to think it is after that he mentions
that i can also share that jeff morrill
our new chief corporate affairs officer
this is one of the folks who used to
work in the george w bush administration
for the record we'll be reassessing our
advocacy strategies around the world
including political giving as he begins
to integrate the communications public
policy and government relations and csr
teams now here's the thing about this
this is the closest they come to saying
that they are going to make any changes
but this right now as it stands is not a
pledge to change it's not a pledge to do
better and it's not an apology for what
happens it is the first part dodging any
direct responsibility for it and this
part saying we are reviewing and
assessing but it doesn't say with what
intent because to simply say that you're
assessing well that's statement of fact
but it's also completely neutral are you
assessing because you intend to change
things so that this sort of thing
doesn't happen again are you assessing
just as a band-aid to make it look like
you did something and have no intention
of doing anything unless you say
something like we are assessing with the
intent of avoiding this kind of outcome
again then the fact that you are
assessing in and of itself is
meaningless
but because they haven't said anything
like that or something to the effect of
look we had other interests that they
were pushing for that we thought were
good things but this is not something
we're okay with or anything to that
effect it would mean dennis baxley could
not imply that disney
wants this which right now he's not only
able to imply he is implying again do
not take his words in a vacuum remember
that this was an answer to a question
specifically about that bill and his
answer was
disney supports all kinds of people who
do all kinds of things he is linking
disney support to the bill by in by
invoking them in answering questions
about that bill he is saying you're on
his side disney you now have a duty to
say no
no we are not because if you don't
they are taking your silence as
agreement and at a certain point those
of us who are inclined to give you the
benefit of the doubt are going to have
to start assuming the same thing gonna
jump in real quick because in the memo
chapic specifically said i do not want
anyone to mistake a lack of statement
for lack of support we're not mistaking
it that's what it is because it's not
simply a matter of you not commenting on
it the people who back this bill are
implying in every way they can without
flat out saying it that you support them
and if you do not say no actually we
don't you are letting that implication
stand unchallenged that is support
whether it is active support or if you
feel it's something more passive it
doesn't matter that is letting them
invoke your name in what they are doing
one other thing that he said in the memo
he said as we have seen time and again
corporate statements do very little to
change outcomes or minds instead they
are often weaponized by one side or the
other to further divide and inflame
simply put they can be counterproductive
and undermine more effective ways to
achieve change now i think i understand
part of what he's trying to convey here
and i understand that for corporations
it is aggravating that very frequently
when they do issue statements of support
or denouncing something they are
frequently told by people like me that
it's not enough because frankly it's not
it's not enough to just say something
you have to also do it but saying is
better than nothing and at this point
the idea of a statement being weaponized
that is a terrible take because your
lack of statement has already been
weaponized by the other side so you not
making a statement means that you are
okay with that side of the argument
weaponizing your lack of statement but
you won't make one because you're afraid
that the allies of lgbtqia plus people
will weaponize that statement ship
sailed it's weaponized already and you
are saying that it's okay for the other
side to have that weapon and we cannot
have it a lack of statement is a lack of
support at this point so what statement
did they make
well they issued a statement through
good morning america which reads thus
we understand how important the issue is
to our lgbtq plus employees and many
others for nearly a century disney has
been a unifying force that brings people
together we are determined that it
remains a place where everyone is
treated with dignity and respect the
biggest impact we can have in creating a
more inclusive world is through the
inspiring content we produce the
welcoming culture we create here and the
diverse community organizations we
support including those representing the
lgbtq plus community
[ __ ] you
you do not
get to talk about how you still support
and are inclusive towards lgbtqia plus
people at the same time that you have
failed to address in any direct way the
manner in which money made by your
company directly contributed to people
who are now pushing forward a bill that
is directly
harmful to trans and queer and the
entire lgbtqia plus spectrum of people
it is harmful to them it is damaging to
schools it is bad for frankly everybody
and you do not get to have your money
tied to the election and re-election of
people who have brought that forward and
then say
we're your friends and allies and you
especially if you are failing to
distance yourself from these outcomes
from this bill from these people from
these donations you especially do not
get to invoke your inspiring
content as an excuse for
anything i have been more than a little
critical of disney in their
representation or lack of representation
of lgbtqia plus people up to this point
this has been going on with me towards
them for years this is absolute nonsense
but what i have always said is i will
take poor representation over no
representation because poor
representation at least means we are
talking about it and we can work on
making it better
and as painfully slow
as disney and its subsidiaries have been
to give us decent inclusion as slow as
they have been to confirm characters as
queer
of any kind much less important
characters in anything related to disney
pixar marvel star wars it has started
happening progress though way too slow
has been moving forward in these tiny
annoyingly incremental steps
this is the first time that i can
remember disney
definitely
backsliding the progress as
infuriatingly slow as it has been
and the fact that your most overt piece
of support for the lgbtqia plus
community being the owl house you
cancelled and a quick note on that dana
terence the creator of the owl house is
pissed loudly vocally and calling out
bob chappic in specific
setting that aside the progress has only
been moving forward it has been getting
better
slowly
too slowly
but it was
until now
none of that
especially when as i said it's been
too slow too incremental too disposable
when that is your inspiring content
that gives you
no
blanket excuse to not address the real
harm being done with your
money on the subject of that inspiring
content there was a letter obtained by
variety which appears to have been
written by lgbtqia plus members of pixar
and their allies and there is some stuff
in it that is very damning for disney in
the letter the employees of pixar
animation allege that the disney
corporate level executives demanded cuts
of nearly every moment of overtly gay
affection regardless of when there is
protest from both the creative teams and
the executive leadership at pixar this
is really bad and it's confirming
something that has been speculated about
for a very long time that the top brass
at disney is putting a clamp down and
heavy restrictions on what little
representation we have even been getting
and to be fair this is actually far more
damning for bob iger than anybody else
because as far as the timing goes for
the sorts of movies being discussed in
this letter he would have been the one
in charge at the time one other thing in
the letter that sums all this up
beautifully is this even if creating
lgbtqia plus content was the answer to
fixing the discriminatory legislation of
the world we are being barred from
creating it which just blows apart the
entire idea that the inspiring content
somehow cancels out the money
contributed to politicians because that
is not even being allowed to happen
without severe restrictions
and do not tell me how little 4 000
total dollars split between two
different state representatives is i
don't care how little it is you put
money behind them and while i am not
going to hold you personally responsible
for that initial donation because as i
said the entire corporate structure
cannot know before these things happen
you know now you know the impact you
have no
right to dodge responsibility for this
bob chapic the disney company as a
parent company
you
have
no right to say that the way you change
the world is with your inspiring content
when there is demonstrable harm being
done with funds directly
brought by you
[ __ ]
off
one final note about the memo it does
seem that to whatever degree the
executives at disney care about the
lgbtqia plus community they are
constantly framing it through their
employees with statements such as while
not perfect our company has a long
history of supporting the lgbtq plus
community and in fact has played an
important role in the personal journeys
of so many of our employees as i stated
before they actually have a very good
track record of taking care of their
employees but their reach goes way
beyond that and they need to acknowledge
that impact and they appear to be trying
to with mentioning their inspirational
content but failing to acknowledge the
negative impact you don't get to take
only the good oh and fun fact turns out
i've been mispronouncing bob's name this
whole time it's not chappic it's jpeg i
am not actually going to be issuing any
kind of apology about that i wouldn't
want my statement to be weaponized and
cause divisiveness later on down the
line but i'll just note it here if
you're going to put things like this
in your stores under your branding it
has to mean
something and i have been a
mild defender of disney up to this point
i have made the argument that despite
the fact that i wish progress was going
fast faster i've made the argument that
even the token representation and
support that we've gotten is still
something because it is them signing off
on the idea that us being normalized us
being a viable demographic us having a
right to be here matters when a company
that big does it but i will not issue
that defense when you give your dollars
to groups and people like this and then
do not address that
fact so jpeg ended up saying a few
things at a virtual meeting that i want
to address real quick firstly it's
interesting that he went through the
entire meeting not addressing this and
it was literally the last thing he did
and i'm not going to go through the
entire thing this video is running long
enough as it is but i'm going to pull
out two specific parts that illustrate
why this is completely insufficient
first there's this we were opposed to
the bill from the outset but we chose
not to take a public position on it
because we felt we could be more
effective working behind the scenes
engaging directly with lawmakers on both
sides of the aisle which almost sounds
like an admission that the bill is about
idea but actually is not firstly the way
chepeg is claiming that they were trying
to adjust it is a way that really is not
confirmable and again we have the direct
invocation of both sides in a situation
where like why why is this a both sides
issue no one on the left was part of
this bill he then said he called the
florida governor something which the
governor's office has confirmed although
that office also confirmed in the same
statement that the governor's stance and
intention to sign the bill has not
changed and then the other thing he said
was that certainly the outcome of
florida was not what many of us were
hoping for especially our lgbtq plus
employees again citing the employees and
almost deferring the concern on to them
this is not something that the company
is unhappy with the outcome of this is
not something he's unhappy with the
outcome of certain people especially
these people again it is associating
himself with people who are absolutely
against this but not actually confirming
it he is skirting so far to the line but
he will not cross it and he is going so
far out of his way he is dancing around
the fact that he will not address
whether or not he or disney as a parent
company support this bill every wording
of this is carefully crafted to avoid
any admission in either direction and
even with the earlier part where he said
that they were against this bill from
the beginning there is no admission of
their part in helping it get created in
the first place no admission of guilt no
mission of regret no responsibility
taken you need to come clean and either
admit
that this
is all
[ __ ] or own up to the fact that you
did harm and made a mistake those are
your two options and if you take neither
i for one am taking that as an
endorsement of what is being done with
your money take some responsibility
because when you
target us
for merchandising
and you sign off and approve of gay days
during pride at disney parks
you have no business
asking for our money and our support
jumping in for what should be the last
time because this thing just keeps on
evolving as the week has gone on
chapeck's latest attempt to make this
all go away without actually issuing any
kind of statement on it has gone very
badly for him he made an announcement
that the disney company would pledge
five million dollars to the human rights
campaign as well as other lgbtqia plus
rights organizations the humans rights
campaign rejected the donation stating
in a response the human rights campaign
will not accept this money from disney
until we see them build on their public
commitment and work with the lgbtq plus
advocates to ensure that dangerous
proposals like florida's don't say gay
or trans bill don't become dangerous
laws and if they do to work to get them
off the books
this is chapeck running out of options
he is clearly doing everything he
possibly can to make this go away up to
now literally throwing five million
dollars at the problem and people are
not swallowing it he is virtually out of
options as far as anything other than
issuing an actual formal statement about
his or the company's stance on this bill
and while i have said in the past i do
believe there is still a net positive
for money donated to a good cause even
if that money was donated in not the
best circumstances i have to take my hat
off to the human rights campaign here
because they effectively said to him hey
you threw a molotov cocktail into a
living room and now you're offering to
redo the driveway we are not going to
let you do that until you explain and
address what it was you did and pledge
to not do it ever again and you know
what
they were right to do so
now
going forward
i'm going to treat this similar to how i
have been treating the issue of the bbc
and transphobia
when i discuss
anything currently controlled by the
disney corporation there will be a
disclaimer and an asterisk at the front
of it
i will still review these things
partly because it is my job it is how i
make my living and i cannot afford to
simply stop talking about marvel or star
wars or disney
however i can point out and i will until
something is done until something is
addressed i will point out in every
video that you are doing this and have
not
said that you will stop doing it and you
have not denounced this law and now
let's cover the thing that happened
yesterday so jpeg sent out another email
to employees which has of course gotten
in the hands of the media i won't be
going through the entire thing you can
certainly read it for yourself but i'm
gonna go through the things that i feel
are necessary to highlight at the end of
the first paragraph he says it is clear
that this is not just an issue about a
bill in florida but instead yet another
challenge to basic human rights yes yes
it is thank you for finally realizing
that you needed me to be a stronger ally
in the fight for equal rights and i let
you down yes yes you did and then
finally he says i am sorry this is late
but these are the words that he has
danced around and refused to say for a
painfully long amount of time despite
the fact that this has only been a
matter of weeks that this has been going
on next paragraph he says our employees
see the power of this great company as
an opportunity to do good i agree yes we
need to use our influence to promote
that good by telling inclusive stories
but also by standing up for the rights
of all this was pretty big because it's
a directive mission that what was said
before about influential stories
inspiring stories and whatnot is not
enough and a recognition of that or at
least an admission of it i mean there's
the usual caveat of how sincere this is
or if it's just put together by a pr
team who knew what needed to be said at
this point i don't know but it is at
least addressing that issue the next
paragraph talks about their political
giving specifically he says we are
pausing all political donations in the
state of florida pending this review now
that's certainly more concrete action
than the reassessing that was mentioned
before it does however not specifically
indicate with what intent and a pause is
just a pause it's not a stop so it does
indicate that they do intend to continue
to do political giving there's mention
in the previous sentences about giving
to more advocacy groups but the
political giving is also separate from
that so it's not really being as direct
as i would have liked but at least
within context it is saying something
not a million miles away from what i was
liking but you know
i'm i'm still gonna critique this he
does say you will hear more about our
progress in coming weeks so he seems to
understood he can't just hide behind the
corporate plan and say well we're
working on it people have eyes on him
now the last thing i want to bring up is
actually the very first sentence and the
context of that this whole thing begins
with to my fellow colleagues but
especially our lgbtq plus community i
think it's worth pointing out that once
again this was not a publicly made
statement this was an internal email
that at this point he must have known
was going to be leaked to the press now
that is about the one major thing that i
still have concerns about he seems to
only be framing this through the lens of
his employees now it's great that he's
looking out for his employees that there
seems to be
at least an understanding that he has to
look concerned about his employees if
not actually a genuine concern but there
is still some question as to how much he
actually understands the impact of the
company outside of the people who
directly work for it there's some token
acknowledgement of it here but the fact
that again this wasn't even a public
statement means that technically he
still hasn't said anything to the
general public he has only spoken to the
company and to the employees and at this
point i have no doubt with full
knowledge that it would get to the
public and be treated like a statement
even though it isn't now that does not
negate what is said here and this is
not quite but it is at least in the
ballpark of what i said i needed from
him and from the company i haven't had
enough time to mull all this over to
decide whether or not i'm still going to
be adding an addendum to the front of
walt disney related reviews or videos
that i do i need to sleep on a little
bit more and also keep an eye on the
follow through for all this but i'm
gonna say that that is on pause
currently being reassessed welcome to
the party bob i guess now you've
realized you can't just sit in the
corner and think that we'll ignore you
all right let's wrap this up i got more
upset talking about this than i had
intended to i really wanted this to be
as calm and
restrained as i could make it
but this is not okay
this bill
is deeply
deeply
harmful
and a company that has found out that
any of its money
and not just from its employees from
actual companies
official companies that are part of it
helped contribute
to the campaigns of people who brought
this about
you do not get to be silent about that
that is all that i have to say
on this issue
i know i got heated
i know it's contentious
and infuriating
be as polite as you can
to me
to
even the representatives and to bob
chappic
because i will not stand for personal
attacks
criticize them all you want
but the minute it gets to
name slinging or unfounded accusations i
will remove it no matter who it's being
thrown at even people who i have a deep
dislike for right now so keep it civil
and if you can do that
drop your thoughts down in the comments
and let's talk about it
patreon is how i'm able to do
what i do and why i'm able to take a
full day to research something like this
if you want to help support my ability
to make this kind of content or anything
else that i do the patreon is the best
way to do that if you're not able to do
so
like share subscribe and the comments
those all help
they help me not get completely ignored
by the algorithm which it likes to do
from time to time
but whatever you decide to do
whatever is next
i need you to remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council i just run the
meetings and until next time
this council is churned
[Music]
it's the end credits means i gotta shout
out some patrons this month it is turok
oliver b linda walters tt robin powell
fronabilax the poodle idoln tracy
scrabbon dharma michael doyle vincent
paul bartolucci angry casper adam lefty
taylor robin moore shayla gourley and
bookworm
thanks so much for your support
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]